n39 friends captors how well you guys
know each other
okay folks math boys the earth decline
to crap services that maybe fit me
properly
Oh Joe Joe need a girl Tiffany was so
happy to be on a sad truth eating free
like we had to show her that like in
some people we're at a ball it's like
this is part of the gig you're okay
things I don't know so why are you to
put it in your for this business I was
feeling food I'm taking some to the
wholesaler thing you were first in line
for crafters how every with that
who is this a therapist do does
everybody know super nice I want to say
Jada Jada I was just thinking Jada
you're adamantly right Jada yeah here's
the stage I always go to data put in
your life and II actually a wealth of
wisdom Jada I'm here animate data wait a
minute hold on one second
Amy everybody yeah everybody said you
and then Tiffany that you and then you
know with mad all relationship advice
and stuff in my garden you let that you
know I know very low real friend like
not just watch playing like real free
yeah here's beneath all like he's
hilarious but I'm going to tell you the
truth is he's really all hard like
that's a soft evening who is the closest
to her character I would say symphonies
definitely there tiffany tiffany yeah
yeah I like that yeah I think you're the
farthest away from the cake help so yes
you would have been like two and you
first to be like
and I had this much fun in so long